hey this is exciting John Leguizamo
might be a david pakman show fan as as
you know i'm on instagram at david
pakman and i have been doing some
tweeting and posting on Instagram and it
has brought John Leguizamo the great
actor out of the woodwork but I'll get
to that in a second okay my second most
popular picture of the week on my
Instagram account david hackman is what
it looks like when I'm live streaming I
did a YouTube live stream yesterday to
talk about the ongoing YouTube funding
crisis that were experiencing and I said
I would put up a picture of what it
looks like when I'm streaming and as you
can see here Pat I've got my laptop in
front of me I've got my HD webcam
plugged in and to the left I have my
blue Yeti microphone which I find to be
a good mic for this type of thing you
have one as well right I do have one as
well yeah this is pretty much everything
that you need I think you may want to
add a drone though to get some other
shots while you're doing these lessons
right yeah I should add a drone
component to the livestream why not and
as we know flying drones endure they're
indoors very very safe thing to do so
yes great idea pad also so now let's get
to John Leguizamo John Leguizamo and I
posted this to my Instagram account
appears to be a fan of the david pakman
show he retweeted our post about the
gerrymandering long-form video that we
did and john leguizamo follows the david
pakman show on twitter you can check out
a picture of the tweet on my Instagram
account is like Inception to check out a
picture of the tweet go to Instagram at
david pakman it's way easier to find it
that way than searching through twitter
and that's john leguizamo a progressive
activist all-around great guy loved him
in season two of the great Netflix show
bloodline he's got a long list of
credits to his name which we're not
going to list now but that's the most
recent thing I saw John Leguizamo in is
this our most famous fan I wonder that
we know of perhaps yeah I mean I know
him as Sid from ice age the loveable
sloth character of course but you know
publicly I should just say I've seen all
of his work in casey's watching right
now yes absolutely and let me also say
if you believe that you're more Fame
John Leguizamo and you are a fan of the
show please come out of the woodwork
because we are having a big funding
crisis right now because of the YouTube
advertiser boycott and there is nothing
that could help us more than some big
name saying I support the david pakman
show i watch or listen to the david
pakman show and so if you want to get in
touch even if you're almost as famous as
john leguizamo please and we often hear
about different people you know for
example Roseanne Barr is familiar with
the show and I've tweeted back and forth
with her I think my politics are
probably more in line with John
Leguizamo is than with Roseanne's more
than likely but that's okay so please
come out of the woodwork and we will
make a big deal out of it and maybe
it'll help us fix this funding gap that
we have we've certainly had quite a few
famous guests for interviews on the show
sure I think that's a little bit
different than someone who follows the
show and tunes in every day yeah and
there are other actors that are fans of
the show no offense to them that they
probably know who they are I've tweeted
with some of them but they're not quite
as well known as John Leguizamo yet they
what they could get there no doubt about
it anyway follow me on instagram at
david pakman